[Music]
one of your most popular if not the most
popular post of yours in 2019 on your
blog was how I practice at what I do I
believe that's the name of the of the
blog post please correct me wrong that's
right and to quote that blog post you
wrote recently one of my favorite
questions to bug people with has been
what is it that you do to train that is
comparable to a pianist practicing
scales if you don't know the answer to
that one maybe you're doing something
wrong or not doing enough could you
elaborate on that please
well say you're a social scientist or
you are a writer or you give public
talks you are out there in some way all
of the time but if you look at people
like say what Kobe Bryant did or what
Martina Navratilova did they practiced
to an extreme degree and that's how they
got better Martina was not world number
one player until she had an intense
regime of proper practice Kobe the older
he got he realized he needed to practice
more whereas a lot of top stars actually
practice less and they coast on
reputation and they have a guaranteed
contract so just everyday you want to be
reading you want to be talking you want
to be thinking you want to be exercising
and do it you know at an intense a level
as you can and just try to do that all
day long
and that's practice and you know one
hopes that will make you better it's not
for you to say but you know that's the
hope how do you practice your skills
what does what does scales look like for
you writing out large quantities of
material much of which I never use or
publish writing out different points of
view which are not my own is also a way
of practicing trying to talk to a very
diverse set of people in my case not
just academics not just people I went to
high school with say listening to highly
complex music I think is a way to keep
your mind active periodically reading
serious fiction I think of something
people stopped doing after they hit a
certain age maybe 30 or 40 but it forces
you to be
to the complexities of how humans
actually are I recommend that to if
someone listening were a nonfiction
purist say they quit at 20 and that had
not been reading fiction since there are
any particular fiction books that you
might recommend for someone to use as
their re-entry to the world of complex
fiction or fiction overall I would have
to know their biography but I would
start with Harold blooms book the
Western canon which has a list and
surveys a lot of his favorite works a
few of which are nonfiction by the way
and dig in there and just find what you
love and pursue it I think the greatest
writer is Shakespeare it's not
necessarily for everyone and if you did
not grow up writing and reading English
it's probably not for you but that would
be one start the Henry odd you know
you